Welcome back to The Morty Jebsen
Show,
I'm Morty Jebsen.
We're here today
continuing our conversation
with unbelievable
mega-superstar Young Bidness.
Now Young Bidness,
I gotta tell you,
we've been tiptoeing around
a particular subject all day
and I think it's time
to broach it.
You've separated recently
with your actress girlfriend
Tina Bouquet?
No, Mort.
And everybody wants to know-
Mort.
We ain't gonna talk about that.
I'm not here to talk about that.
I understand.
I just want to hear
your side of the story.
You don't want to hear.
I told y'all motherfuckers
we weren't going to talk
about that, Mort.
In your music, Young Bidness,
you do
a lot autobiographical songs.
I'm trying to talk
about the music.
And lots of people understand
that you're talking about
your own personal experiences.
See, Mort, I ain't-
Your fans would like to know
what's going on
with you and Tina.
The fans don't wanna know.
You wanna know.
We just wanna clarify.
You don't wanna clarification.
All I wanna do is clarify.
I wanna hear your side
of the story.
I'll tell you my side
Morty Jebsen:
I wanna hear your side
of the story.
Interview's over.
How 'bout that?
Interviews over.
Please, Young Bidness.
Done.
There's no need
for the interview to be over,
Young Bidness.
Interview's over.
All y'all motherfuckers.
Young Bidness there's no need
for the language or any of this.
We can just sit down and talk.
All y'all.
I told y'all motherfuckers
I wasn't gonna talk about that.
Do you want to talk about
the album?
Because I'd be more than happy
to talk about the album.
This The C-Word.
Mort.
It looks like it's well
on its way to going Platinum,
or CD as it were.
Get the fuck away from me.
Lewis, Lewis. Well on its way
to going Platinum.
We can talk about this,
it's kind of a double album,
wouldn't you say?
This shit is tucked in here...
It's fine with me.
You wanna talk about the album?
We can talk about the album.
How 'bout the tanks of truth?
Tanks of truth?
Is that a treatise
on the conflict with ISIS?
I mean, what is,
talk to me about this?
Young Bidness, please.
I'm begging you.
Sit down, take a deep breath,
and let's discuss.
Let's discuss the album.
No. It's done, Mort. It's done.
Okay, Young Bidness.
You brought this
on yourself, Mort.
Young Bidness,
I would really love it-
Young Bidness:
You brought it
on yourself, though.
Young Bidness, Young Bidness
I would really love it
if you had a seat
and we could just talk
together about anything,
anything you want.
I won't mention
Tina's name again.
Young Bidness.
How the fuck.
Youthful commerce.
How does, where does it go tO?
Lewis, help him.
Get the fuck,
get the fuck off me, Lewis.
Lewis ... Go.
Leave it be. You're exacerbating
the situation.
This shit attached to?
It's probably ...
It's just a lot of slack.
The cord is blending
in with the color of the carpet.
I just think that,
Young Bidness,
why don't you drop
the mic cable and have a seat.
This goes there ...
This is what we used
to call back
in the Army a FUBAR.
See, now I've got this ...
Okay, let me just tell you
what's going on.
No, don't get involved. You see?
We just have to get you
out of here.
Amy, please? Can we just get ...
Why is it ...
Listen, here.
Okay. No, don't.
If you let go of it.
Here, let me get in.
Don't get in it. Don't- see?
I'm trying to get
around the back.
Don't step on my jacket.
$1,500 jacket, bitch.
Why do we have black cords
and a black carpet?
All right,
well you motherfuckers-
I told y'all I wasn't let ...
Lewis, I swear
to fucking God.
We're going to take care of it.
Just stay put.
Now you got-
Now I seem to have gotten myself
tangled in it.
Don't. You ain't- get off me.
Can I, may I help you?
Don't touch the jacket.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Look, okay, here's-
Raise your knee.
Here's one end right here.
You gotta get down.
Hold on, I've got bursitis.
You know what, here.
Here's what we're going to do.
Okay.
Have a seat here.
Put your fanny here.
Don't say fanny.
Right there.
All right. How do you do this,
you do this every ...
Don't, you ain't
taking the pants off.
Nicole, God damn it.
Where is Jerry?
This is some shit right here.
Same sound guy for 27 years.
What's wrong with you?
Vanishes into thin air.
All right,
all right,
all right. No.
Nicole, for God's sake.
All right. Lewis, Lewis.
Hold that. Don't do anything
but hold that.
Okay, no, no. Y'all. No.
Nigga. You can't take the pants
off over the shoes.
You can't take the pants
off over the shoes!
Lewis, Lewis get
your white ass
out the motherfucker.
You ain't helping nobody.
Vanishes into thin air ...
All right, all right.
I'm taking the shoes off.
Okay. Left one first.
Well, fuck, do whatever
the fuck you want then nigga.
But fine. Thank you.
One, two. Thank you.
I told y'all, I wasn't going
to talk about that shit.
We'll be right back
with Alec Baldwin.